we will be in touch commander Thank You
agent 47 right so let's just have a
quick look at a second at how
engineering okay I got that lady is the
most annoying person right um I'd like
to okay we don't have enough money to
build lab it's fine I'd rather save the
money from that okay maybe we should
have taken the money oh well that's fine
right let's go to the Situation Room my
god is that oh no that's not so if this
is the situation room was going to win
satellite coverage so we should plan our
deployments careful okay so i've already
started building let's go back I've
already started building three two one
at least one satellite to put over these
countries so we vote were based in
Nigeria and we have a satellite
automatic over there but we need to
start putting satellites in um in these
areas particularly you can in India and
apparently Belfast people have written
in hob attacking aliens great sounds
like Belfast to be fair okay that was
good for a first mission that was well
we somebody did die it wasn't ideal but
you know we're getting that we can
actually see though that I love this you
if you zoom in you can see if we got
here I think that's Galileo talking
these people are all going to be later
that's all I'm not sure that might be
mmm there might be Hypatia it might be
here a stray kitten she was at the start
the bloody video Carolina Herschel and
then there's a bar which i think is that
it's that Kepler no I don't know oh I've
never actually looked at some of these
rooms no that's Hypatia and I think
that's kept further wow they're getting
on splendidly better watch that one
that's fanfiction waiting to happen okay
so now what we have to do is either wait
at the end of the month we'll take
another mission which is going to give
us money so for that Oh science science
is happening you're telling me that we
should risk the lives of our troops so
we can take one of these things alive
yes without a live specimen I'm afraid
we've reached the pinnacle of what my
team is able to accomplish of course
she's German and how do you suggest we
do this doctor they want obviously I
just completed confirms that the aliens
physiology is quite similar to our own a
highly concentrated electrical current
delivered at close range should cause
miram close range and what happens if it
doesn't work do you really think this is
worth the risk I do we do not know our
enemy how can we hope to stop something
that we do not understand if we can
capture one of these creatures alive we
may be able to communicate with it and
interrogated find out what they want
where they're operating from yes that
possibility outweighs all risks in my
head in the comments where's that quite
often a facility to house our captive
but I do not know how he could possibly
communicate with it not to worry I was
all right I'll speak to the commander
cuz I'm he's American she's German
where's that guy from dr. Shen the
engineering guy it's just sort of this
foreign person I don't know what I
accent is ok so we've done the first bit
of research incidentally if you try an
Electra shot one of your examiner's it
doesn't help I tried so blah blah a
little bit fluff we now know a little
bit about the fact that we need to
electrocute our enemies and we can build
alien containment so this is the thing
which allows us to capture aliens we
could research the weaponry which
explodes when you kill the alien so we
could work out how that works work a
little bit about what they build things
from so this basically will help us
build body armor I think and the autopsy
well I'm not actually sure how that
helps you to be honest at this stage I
think the armor is man it says this is
our priority I'm gonna go for the armor
because I've already put the new
recruits to work in the lab I'm still
having a haha it is the aliens are
prepared to accomplish are they studying
us why abduct humans seemingly at random
there must be a pattern that we haven't
established yet are you the person that
incidentally put this satellite dish
underground because that definitely
looks like a radio telescope just saying
like I don't know how much each you're
gonna get out of it from underground
anyway she's so annoying well I'm just
I'm grumpy maybe that's just it i don't
like being interrupted yeah people died
way too easily in this game so i think
armors just that's gonna help us
basically ok
this guy was someone in the cheat or
omission that was injured quite badly it
wasn't that actually wasn't my owner
that was my fault the guy who died
wasn't my fault at all okay so we can
build the nanofiber vests so we can
build things and give them to our
soldiers to make them more effective and
that can include our mechanic weaponry
this thing though will be a help it will
actually help us not die quite so
quickly experimental warfare this does
not choose any resources this needed ten
weapons fragments and we only have seven
so this doesn't use anything the sector
one let's go for this one I expected
that would be a priority research how
did you I'll begin allocating resources
to the project immediately ah Thank You
stereotype female scientist why can't he
be hypatius he's way call the new chief
oh oh oh there's a flying brain scramble
interceptors oh oh oh I forgot you had
to manage these right let's take this
thing down hopefully with this way
varsity of a complicated launching
system
oh yeah okay spot-on every seven we have
a confirmed kill 001 I repeat the UFO is
down i'll copy over solid copy brutal 37
nice work central app all right people
retest recon satellite Bravo and get me
a visual on that crash site she's coming
into range now sir it was directly
overhead magnify
still in one piece commander I recommend
we get a strike team to the crash site
immediately the satellite was directly
overhead there is no need to wait okay
right we've got a mission let's do this
we're gonna send our sky Ranger again
this guy i should probably rename him
although he's british so i can actually
get replacing with a proper british
scientist from this rough period this
weird kind of well I mean I patience n
cheree Copernicus was from the 15th
century and Kepler's from the 16th
century so it's quite a quite a broad
range to fair but it's got a huge you're
nobody let's bring in Galileo Galilei
okay ice launched the mission
strike one you could have Walt thought
that is so lazy listen up we're going to
be dropping you deep in the Nigerian
interior for the next operation it looks
like the aliens went down in a sparsely
populated area if there are civilians in
the area I hope they stay clear okay
depending on which part of Nigeria
crash-landed in we might actually be
chilly and Boko Haram might have already
taken them hostage to be fair a pretty
pity Boko Haram for the first time
that's true okay strike one is
authorized to assault the alien craft
good okay let's get our eyes on the
ground so Hypatia is really interesting
actually so she's sort of the next in
chronology along from Archimedes I hope
that means she isn't gonna die oh I
don't like those sound effects um okay
Galileo cool see ya Hypatia she is so
typical of women throughout history in
that she's one of any female scholars
from antiquity which she was at she was
a philosopher and mathematician she
actually headed a philosophical school
in Alexandria when it was under Greek
control but there are no works that
survived that we can directly a tribute
to her anything which survives from her
potentially people tend to write off as
a collaboration with her father oh god
we supposed to go in this direction am I
completely missing the port where are we
supposed to go oh no that's definitely
okay Copernicus let's get you up here
you know so it's the one thing is
difficult to determine what she a stick
did but
Oh God the sound effects of creeped me
out uh-huh but there's also the issue
that she was killed and this was in 415
ad she was killed by a Christian mob and
one of the accounts had that she had her
skin pulled off of her when she was
alive with broken pottery shards was
really gruesome or getting our first
glimpse of her and Christians Christian
Christian accounts at the time had some
trouble determining what their policy
was they couldn't quite decide whether
she was virtuous or whether she was a
witch and some people seem to think that
because she was a woman doing things in
maths and she did things like build
improved astrolabes and she built
musical instruments and she was as
amazingly multi talented woman but yet
people were suspicious because she was a
woman I think okay just say this is
definitely not in one piece look at this
it's a mess I don't like how how close
this is all becoming so I can Ritsuko
panic is ability by the way because he's
an assault if I hit a select run and gun
it allows me to fire after I've moved
again but I don't want to use that
unnecessarily this um I don't like this
I really don't like this
but as we as we demonstrated Hypatia was
apparently a complete badass with rocket
launcher they did they didn't movie
about her recently I think a Rachel vice
but it was a bit too serious that's the
other thing is that like I'd love to do
I was actually thinking the other day
about writing a screenplay about Galilei
Galileo sorry cuz it's really all this
all these people are so so interesting
sorrys textures are really weird it's
not meant to be water or swamp may be
okay um oh that's okay but you know she
was an amazing person even if she didn't
necessarily contribute huge amounts to
modern science I'm gonna regret doing
this no I'm not gonna be the other I'm
gonna keep your overwatch but she
especially represented the fact that
women ever from the Classical period
from antiquity it could make just as
important contributions okay they're
more the same the more step towards hmm
ok right Copernicus if I get you down
there will you die possibly
my readings can't be right yep you're
wrong when basically and we are also in
very deep trouble oh boy okay I ideally
don't want to destroy anything that's in
this because that's really valuable from
research perspective I'm also going to
run because I get the impression it how
cowardly would it be do you think to
just sit here and take potshots like on
a scale of one to coward Lee okay we
know they're there maybe they will get
old and just decide to come to us so
there's two that this being of pure
energy in inverted commas over there god
I sound like such a bloody physicist
uh-huh it's like have you watched the
Avengers of course you watch The
Avengers if you're watching this video
you'll almost certainly watch The
Avengers and at the top and start our
there's the force field protecting the
tesseract and Jarvis says impenetrable
is pure energy I was in a visit a cinema
in a row or physicist and everybody just
went at that
because of course I'll go on high
patient go on
yes threat neutralized oh wow yes you
kicked butt so she's been promoted let's
try and not to get her killed um
paniscus can you ten percent Lance if we
switched to the pistol fifty percent
let's try that yeah that was nowhere
near no you won't with that kind of
attitude you won't mmm is it worth
sending somebody around to the other
side's Galileo Kepler indistinguishable
from the game's perspective is it worth
sending one of your aunt's flank gone
gotta be brave okay Hypatia you're gonna
go an overwatch again Kepler I want you
to move up I'm getting emotionally
invested in this already all right okay
mrs. are a sniper would be really
helpful alright let rip no Matt it go on
go on go on not like that
well you don't say okay okay so you can
actually get in okay right I'm gonna put
you an overwatch there that's probably a
very dangerous thing to do I mean I'm
disinclined mmm know if he's explosives
that set wit balls Copernicus 50 cent
come on be a man oh yeah freak when sis
the probability [ __ ] did you very
much damage because it was a pistol but
you know
right come on get it can't go there he's
gonna take a shot Oh critical hit that's
not good con Kepler yes come on come on
yes like-for-like and you've got a
promotion okay Galileo you are in a bad
way hmm what to do what to do okay I
took thing is you're not relevant for
like a couple of episodes so if he dies
are we can clone you I'm sure it's fine
um where are you getting supported from
okay somewhere over there I want to keep
Hypatia up here on overwatch
if I do this are you gonna die withstand
an impact like that at such a velocity
the materials used in that vessels home
must be at least an order of magnitude
beyond any element we know of an order
of magnitude in what that this makes aah
mmm video game logic everyone can you
take it out check it out yes I was not
expecting that to work that was amazing
um do I want to send you running well
you do still have a chance of taking him
Alice anything I pay [ __ ] you're a shot
oh you do right hang on you're pretty
reliable that's the seat ok not this
time no way that just happened yep well
it did oh there you are I take you out
alright if we can take you out the other
one will die as well yes drugged up
another nobody died nobody bloody died
okay Galileo got a little bit shut up
that's that's that's good but it's not
good but you know you didn't die woof
that's why this is what happened in the
space of like 24 hours these guys must
be antsy shattered I can't see what
happened oh okay so she's hit that's not
ideal